avant la réunion avant le paradis avant
le rêve on va faire une interview
cauchemar
[Musique]
sur les stars
vous vivez ou dans vos cauchemars je
fais pas que je m'en
fais pas ta pas un autre truc à
l'interview cheval et non mais elle est
bien c'est une interview à 10 ans je
fais des cauchemars et est déjà là ce
soir pourquoi c'est un cauchemar je suis
un cauchemar dont votre copine elle vous
trompe avec qui dans vos cauchemars
j'ai appris beaucoup rencontres ont pu
noter cauchemar est il va la tabasser
crois que c'est
un peu con doigts
c'est quoi votre métier de jouer dans
vos cauchemars
des mouches j'écoutais quoi comme
musique dans vos cauchemars stomy bugzy
ça bien
c'est qui qui est en tête du top 50 dans
vos cauchemars
vous avez peur de quoi dans vos
cauchemars iam
vous mourrez commandant au cauchemar en
écoutant du sommet mais aussi nous
montrer à quel âge dans vos cauchemars à
l'âge des cerises et
vous découvrez quoi sur vous dans vos
cauchemars
que je ressemble à pacy
vous fait attaquer par quel genre
d'animal dans vos cauchemars un
sarcellois
ressemble à quoi l'humanité dans vos
cauchemars c'est parce que ça me ferait
de pire cauchemar ouais vous ayez sur
quel plateau télé dans vos cauchemars tu
as je fais drucker thaler 1 pas mal
alors c'était pas mal et les onze
manchester et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater le in a l'habitude abonnez vous y
mettez un peu de bleu